[موسيقى]
جنيفر لورانس حققت افلامها اكثر من سته
مليارات دولار في جميع انحاء العالم
وكانت الممثله الاعلى اجرا في العالم في
عام 2015
كما ظهرت في قوائم الشخصيات الاكثر تاثيرا
وشهره قبل ان تبني ثروه طائله وهي في
بدايه عقدها الثلاثين فما قصتها
ولدت جنيفر لورانس عام
1990 في ولايه كنتاكي الامريكيه والدها
ملك لشركه انشاءات ووالدتها مديره المخيم
الصيفي في مكان الطفله موهبه ومتحمسه
للانشطه الترفيهيه والرياضيه
فغالبا ما ذهبت للتشجيع في المنافسات
الرياضيه وقامت ببعض عروض الازياء والمسرح
المجتمعي ولكنها ظنت انها قد تكون طبيبه
ولم تحلم ابدا بان تصبح ممثله
بالمصادفه واثناء رحله لها مع عائلتها الى
مدينه نيويورك رصدتها وكاله للكشف عن
المواهب ورتبت لها موعدا لاجراء اختبار
لادوار مختلفه حينها واجهت رفضا مبدايا من
والدتها التي كانت تربيها لتكون قويه
وقاسيه كاخوتها لم تكن تريدها ان تتجه الى
مهنه التمثيل ولكنها اذعنت اخيرا فقامت
جنيفر بدور ثانويا في مسلسل تلفزيوني يسمى
كامباني تاون عام 2006 لكنه لم يباث على
التلفاز
انهد جينيفر دراستها الثانويه مبكرا
لتلتحق بمهنه التمثيل فظهرت كممثله لاول
مره في عام 2007 في المسرحيه الهزليه
لكن التحول الحقيقي كان في عام 2008 حيث
قدمت ادوار الناجحه في ثلاثه افلام هي
جاردن بارتي وذا بيرنق بلاين الى جانب
فيلم ذا بوكر هاوس الذي لعب دور اكبر
اشقائها الثلاثه الذين يعيشون مع ام مدمنه
مخدرات وفازت عنه بجائزه الاداء المتميز
بمهرجان لوس انجلوس السينمائي
الصعود باعمالها وتاهلت لاول مره لجائزه
الاوسكار عندما لعبت دورا مثيرا لمراهقه
فقيره في فيلم دراما وانترزون عام 2010
كما اسهم في جعلها النجمه يتسابق لجذبها
المنتجون
فيهم فحققت نجاحات مذهله في العديد من
الادوار اللاحقه كدوري متحوله متغيره
الشكل في فيلم اكس مان وقائده انثى في
فيلم ذا هانجر جيمز وامراه تنزعج من ضيوف
غرباء في فيلم مازر
المنعطف الاهم في مسيرتها كان في عام 2012
حين مثلت في الكوميديا الرومانسيه سيلفر
وهو العمل الذي اهلها للفوز بجائزه اوسكار
لافضل ممثله بالاضافه الى جائزه جولدن
كلوب وهي لا تزال في الثانيه والعشرين من
عمرها
خلال مسيرتها قدمت جنيفر اكثر من 25 عملا
استطاعت خلالها ان تحصد اكثر من 50 جائزه
فنيه بالاضافه الى جولدن جلوب والاوسكار
كجائزه البافتا والام تي في والروح
المستقله وجائزه جمعيه نقاد السينما في
لوس انجلوس والاكاديميه الاسريه للفنون
وغيرها
وبحلول عام 2014 كانت جنيفر في قائمه فورس
للممثلات الاكثر نفودا اليوم باتت الطفله
التي جلست كثيرا في منصات تشجيع الرياضه
واحده من المشاهير التي يتابعها العالم
عبر شاشه الكبيره
160 مليون دولار وهي لم تتجاوز الثلاثين
من عمرها
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]